good okay thanks all right just get back
to where I was um right so yeah what is
3D for why do we need 3D representations
why do we need 3D models like why don't
we just mask Sora for videos everything
um I think there's a few reasons that we
might want to do this and a lot of them
are tied into the just inherent fact
that we exist in an ambient 3D World so
um you know when thinking about things
like uh autonomous vehicles and robots
and other things that have to interact
with the world sometimes you know it's
like you're safe to just do pixel
actions but in some cases you want maybe
not to make the policy work necessarily
you just want some kind of like
contractural guarantee uh that you have
sensors that are indicating to you that
like I'm not going to hit a person or a
thing or like an animal or a bike if I
if I drive this direction at this
velocity for the next you know 100
milliseconds or something um so in this
case like you actually want that to just
take a very basic geometric measurement
about the world uh and there's cases
that are not to do with like driving
your robotics right just like you know
renovating your house or like things
like that where people have these kind
of like AR apps where you can take
underlying measurements without using a
ruler or a tape measure uh and all this
comes down to just like you want to know
rigorous accurate spatial measurements
about the world in a lot of cases uh
kind of like the next level up from that
I think is this idea of like simulating
a reality that does not yet physically
exist but that you want to make
observations about so kind of a classic
Rend ing case of this is architectural
previs where you know you have some nice
like CAD architectural diagrams uh in
your computer and you want to say like
okay if the Sun is here like if it's
this kind of weather or whatever how's
my house going to look like is this
going to be nice is it going to suck is
it going to be like blinding me while
I'm in the kitchen um like how's a flow
of light through the room or something
like that uh and you know other famous
cases of this like Ikea you know doesn't
actually stage the pictures for the
catalog anymore they mostly just have a
huge uh backlog of 3D models that they
like set up for uh each of the different
layouts they have and then they can do
this customization like per country like
different cultural stuff really easily
without having to actually like
painstakingly do this thing uh in the
real world uh and of course you know
like CG for games and movies is a is a
massive industry uh and that's all you
know at the current moment like all of
these tool chains and pipelines are
backed by underlying 3D representations
physical simulation like renderers and
things like that um so this is kind of a
way of you know if you don't want to be
like Christopher N or whatever you can
actually film something for not like
hundreds of millions of dollars and like
a massive amount of physical destruction
you can actually just run this thing as
many times as you want and Stage it uh
and just burn a bunch of CPU or GPU
hours I think there's also this kind of
like other level on top of that where
because people are in like a physical 3D
World they kind of intuitively
understand that as an interface for
interacting with stuff um this actually
doesn't pan out in a lot of it it pans
out in two really specific ways I think
one is games and then the other one is
AR and VR right so like AR and VR
there's a reason people find like you
know hand controllers or like hand
gestures and stuff really compelling uh
and it kind of like immerses you into
that Medium because it's a much more
direct method of control than like dual
joysticks where you kind of like have
this unnatural thing you have to learn
and pick up and get good at when you're
trying to play a game but even that you
know I think people find the idea of
just being immersed in like some
parallel 3D Universe to be sufficiently
compelling that they're willing to
sacrifice the brain plasticity to learn
how to like use a second joystick um
so I think there's that's a that's a
variety of areas where there is some
level of 3D involved in like the current
way it's done in software and Hardware
um I think not all of these necessarily
need to be 3D I think a lot of this like
simulation for VFX uh another kind of
like creative applications they don't
necessarily need that underlying uh 3D
structure guarantee um but in some of
these cases it's really like you know
it's necessary right like pass through
for the Apple headset like that needs to
show you what's it's kind of a implicit
contract with the device that like
you're showing me pass through like I'm
not going to walk into a chair that's
not there it needs to be kind of uh
accurate to the
world so this kind of gets to the
question of okay um when are we doing
reconstruction when are we doing
generation when are we kind of like on
this slide and continue in between uh
and when does it matter uh and I think I
would classify reconstruction at a very
high level as okay we have a lot of
observations observations or
measurements of some underlying signal
maybe that's abstracted through some
forward model right like the classic
case here would be you take a 2d picture
of a 3D scene uh and then you're going
to try to invert those to recover some
representation of the underlying signal
and here the assumption is like you're
actually trying to get the thing that
was there right you're trying to take
enough pictures enough observations that
you can get a reasonable reconstruction
and you're not hallucinating too much uh
as opposed to I think generation tends
to imply that okay we're kind of fine
with with making stuff up that we don't
observe uh we might have like a purely
unconditional generative model or we
might more often want to have some kind
of like very loose control or you might
have like text string or a single image
or some other kind of like semantic
input that conditions out the full
distribution to get us like a sample
that we actually care about right we
have like I want to do a single image
reconstruction AKA generation of like an
object or a room um or you know I want
to give a text query and get an input
video an output video from that
um uh and I think something that like
you get at a lot with video models
versus 3D is this notion that like
people have been driving the video
models further and further and further
of course like Sor is now like clearly
the The Flash example of this uh and and
it's like kind of like adapting to get a
lot of these capabilities that people
weren't sure were going to be emergent
just with like scaling data and
architectures but it still has like this
last level of okay if you watch the
video for long enough your brain is like
wait that is not how that physically
could be if I like moov the camera in
that way um so if you kind of like any
individual one second clip looks really
good and then if you watch it for like
five 10 20 30 seconds you start to get
these kind of optical spatial Illusions
um that trick your brain a little bit
and I think like I would not go out on a
limb and say that this can't be fixed by
just like more money more gpus more data
um but I do think that it kind of hints
at an underlying thing where okay even
beyond that like Baseline level of um
consistency there's also the idea of
controllability right like what if I
want to change the camera path or what
if I want to like put something in the
scene that like respects exclusions that
would happen in the physical world I
think those things are places where you
might have an advantage in dropping to a
more 3D
interface okay so that's just some very
high level motivation on like 3D why I
continue to be interested in it why I've
been interested for a for a long time um
for Nerf I was coming much more from the
the Reconstruction perspective but in
the last couple years I've been getting
more and more interested in in
generative side things okay um so what
is Nerf uh Nerf stands for neural
Radiance Fields um it's a method
specifically for the computer vision
task of Novel view synthesis uh so the
idea of nov synthesis is okay there's
this notion of kind of like regular
rendering in graphics in 3D Graphics we
basically we have some like detailed
specification of a scene in a computer
we know where everything is we know like
the shapes of things we know their
colors their materials we know where the
lights are uh and we're going to take
all of that process it simulate a camera
looking at the scene like trace a bunch
of Brays or rasterize a bunch of
polygons and get out a single output
image that hopefully looks you know like
we wanted it to um and this is kind of
one of the like classic motivating
examples of the the Corell box I think
from the 80s or something where these
researchers at Cornell like physically
built this box and put a light on top of
it and took a picture of it with a CCD I
guess a CCD digital camera at the time
uh and then they said okay can we go and
manually specify like you know in the 3D
ukian space in the computer where all
these walls are what their colors are
like where the light was and then run
some kind of rendering algorithm such
that we can kind of pass this visual
Turing test of making the image on the
right look like the image on the left um
and I think at the time they were like
okay we did it uh the next couple you
know three decades of computer Graphics
research was basically like this but for
more and more complicated things right
and I think somewhat in like maybe the
mid 2000s is uh that essentially
saturated H and people were pretty much
happy with the state of uh photo
realistic rendering uh and it started to
kind of like roll into production in the
next like 20 years until now uh and I I
think a lot of you may have noticed uh R
tracing is this like really big Paradigm
in games and in video graphics cards
over the last like I don't know five or
so years um there was kind of a parallel
roll of that in the five years before
with with the movie and VFX industry
actually it took you know a good decade
or so after a lot of these rate tracing
algorithms were introduced for them to
actually make it into to Film Production
because of just like cost and you know
research Tech dead and all this stuff
and like things that work in theory for
like a couple cigarette paper figures
but not that robustly in practice for
all the stuff people want to simulate in
movies but you know we're now at the
state where like you can do this for
like pretty much anything you specify by
hand as a cgc if you have like a team of
3D artists um working for many many
hours to to create sufficiently detailed
assets um uh so the motivating force
behind basically all of my research like
through my PhD and until now is this
idea of okay that's actually really
really really hard and really expensive
and if you try to learn blender and like
model a scene it's very painful um and
you a bunch of YouTube tutorials about
donuts and all this stuff um so the idea
is like okay and at the end of that like
you still kind of have this some candy
Valley thing right you're still not
really capturing the full richness of a
real world scene especially like you
know even one as simple as this on a
Surface right this is just like there's
like a road there's like a a a thing
like a wall in the background with some
graffiti and there's this motorcycle but
like that is an incredibly rich and
detailed scene actually right the the
the motorcycle itself would be this like
really expensive CG asset if you modeled
it properly even just getting like a
nice texture and the right material on
the ground here this is all very
challenging so the idea is like okay how
can I as like a lay person go and
essentially get a 3D capture of the
scene that lets us render novel views of
it without needing to do any of that
behind the scenes work by hand uh just
by some like automated 3D reconstruction
process and in particular with bu
synthesis there's a a very specific
focus on having very high quality output
images you're not necessarily caring
about like okay is the like geomet tric
metric accuracy of this reconstruction
super precise are we going to get like
exact material properties out all you
care about like is psnr and like L Pips
and stuff essentially you want to see
like do these images look really good um
and you know we spent you the next five
or so years after Nerf like or four
years scaling this thing up to work on
larger and larger scenes uh so that
actually was a video the previous one
was not even a video of nerf it was a
paper before Nerf uh and then this is
output from zip Nerf from like a year or
year and a half ago uh this is John
capturing his house and then the fly
through of his house that we made
afterward using um the zip Nerf
algorithm so you know this is basically
him taking random photos and then we
spline a nice camera path through at the
end to get this kind of like cinematic
video yeah yeah like I said so if we
wanted to do like a proper computer
Graphics uh path tracing rendering of
the scene we would actually need a full
de decomposition of the geometry the
materials the lighting um but we
specifically in synthesis just boil us
down to a much easier problem of saying
like we only want to move the camera
everything else can say the same we want
to move the camera and see like kind of
the correct inclusion effects see the
correct reflectance effect so you see
like you know the reflection off the the
puddle in the background there and that
should be correctly
preserved okay so that's that's the
motivating um problem statement behind
uh Nerf and like other work we did on
this area before um Nerf was a yeah it
was an eccv 2020 paper was like uh the
last thing we did before Co essentially
um it was me pul and Matt jointly
working together in Ren's group at the
time uh me and Matt graduated pretty
much right after that I think Matt uh
just finished a year a year ago roughly
um and then yeah me and purul ended up
joining John's group at Google for the
next couple years until I just left um
and uh Ren has actually gone to a lot of
work on on human Vision his new group is
really focused on like kind of retinal
scanning and things like that um
okay so first I'll give this very high
level overview of the pipeline and then
I'll get into the kind of like
mathematical details behind some of the
the
specifics um so yeah this is like the or
like pipeline figure from the original
paper um this is depicting the process
of rendering out A View From a Nerf
representation uh in in the in the
process of of training and
reconstructing the scene um so the idea
here is like okay like I said you have a
bunch of captured input images of the
scene and you want to take those to
derive some 3D reconstruction that let
to render new views uh you actually
assume that you have not only those
input images but also their camera pose
extrinsics and intrinsics um this is
like with a ton of caveats a sort of
thing you can assume as solv like this
is a thing a lot of papers are written
assuming this is like given to you uh
that's kind of like under the rug truce
of that is like if the scene doesn't
pose we throw it away and we get a new
one so um I would
say if you are familiar with capturing
scenes in a way that lets them be posed
you can get basically like a 95% success
rate but but this is not yet solved to
the extent like someone could go and
post every video on YouTube there's like
a big difference between intentional
capture for reconstruction and like
posing video in the wild but like okay
let's say you can run call out or some
slams thing and you could get your your
calibrated cameras so once you have that
um now you have essentially like a bunch
of cameras and a bunch of images and
like an empty scene in the middle uh so
the idea is like we're going to trace
we're going to pick random pixels in The
observed images and we're going to trace
those Rays out from the cameras just
using you know standard 3D computer
vision geometry uh and we sample points
through the the bounded volume of the
seam along a tray we take those points
we pass them through some 3D
representation that's going to give us
an output color value uh and an output
opacity value which essentially
represents the geometry of the scene
right this opacity over the course of
conversions essentially goes from like
uh kind of like transparent and mushy to
something that's pretty binarized to
like either zero or one so you're kind
of like marching along the aray each
point along the aray you ask okay is
there a shape here and if there is what
color is it and after you got all those
values you use volume rendering or Alpha
compositing to compute the final color
per Ray so you say okay for all of the
samples along this Ray what was the
color and opacity composite that back to
front get some output value and then you
compare that to what the ground Troth
value was in The observed images so if
you take you know like pixel 2 3 4 5 6 s
from training image number seven you
render that array uh and then you just
take an L2 loss on what the the output
like synthetic Nerf rendered color was
uh and you do gradi descent on that for
like a few thousand iterations with
random batches of pixels each time uh
and you can actually reconstruct pretty
detailed uh synthetic objects in the
case of the original paper uh and these
kind of restricted forward-facing scenes
as we call them where we did kind of
like a window style capture of the
camera only facing in One Direction uh
we we we ended up lifting or us and many
other people lifted this restriction
later but at the times this was kind of
like a compromise to to keep the scene
in a relatively bounded volume
okay um so now I'll get into the the
kind of underlying rendering equation
that governs this process of of actually
taking the output density and color and
converting them into a final um 2D value
for each pixel in the
image okay so I think a good a good high
Lev like three-word summary of Nerf is
that it's a neural volumetric rendering
method um and in particular I I think
rendering here implies that like there
is an underlying 2D representation
neural implies that we use this like
sort of learned MLP scen representation
and volumetric implies that we're
specifically not using a surface
rendering model which is kind of one of
the main points of Distinction uh and
each of these things I'll go over this
again later but like each of these
aspects was not a thing that like Nerf
proposed in any way right like basically
it all existed for for decades um but we
just sort of unified them and showed
that you could achieve very good 3D
reconstruction AB synthesis result by
putting these elements together and in
particular the volum rendering is
something where like there's kind of
this backstory of I think around 2015 to
2020 people were doing a lot of work to
figure out ways you could differentiably
render hard surfaces like people would
blur them in 2D space they blur them in
3D space they do all this kind of stuff
to approximate getting a gradient
because it's just this fundamental issue
that if you're rendering a hard surface
you either hit the surface or you don't
hit the surface and that is
discontinuous and does not technically
have like a derivative you have to rely
on the fact that like oh I'm integrating
over like a pixel footprint and that
gives us like a smooth out version of
the rendering or are these other things
uh versus volume rendering just very
naturally has a trivial derivative uh if
you just implement it in you know tensor
blow Pi torch whatever um and the
difference here is like okay with uh
with surface
rendering in okay actually this is an
implementational detail in surface
rendering you end up kind of looping
over every discrete piece of geometry in
the surface uh and you check whether or
not that hits the ray so you say like
for every triangle in this bunny is that
going to ude the array or is the going
to miss
it and in contrast to that for volume
rendering you do this kind of like Ray
first Loop where you take these samples
along the array and for each of those
you just directly clear you like is
there chomet here there not um and you
can tell like immediately there's a
clear like complexity wise disadvantage
to doing the loop along along the aray
because you're obviously traversing a
ton of empty space but it turns out I
think that's actually one of the key
things that lets the uh gradient descent
based optimization work so well with
volume rendering because
you don't know a prior where the surface
is and the problem with like
initializing a surface rendering
algorithm is like you have to put it
somewhere so you put like a sphere some
proxy geometry and that has to kind of
like work its way from the wrong place
to the right place whereas with volume
rendering especially if you have like an
MLP or a grid based representation you
can just instantiate density wherever
you want along the aray and then the
game of this is kind of like okay once
the thing has started to converge let's
find a way to skip all this like garbage
empty space that we're we're needlessly
oversampling uh over time and kind of
have this like multiphase optimization
where you like cut that stuff
out okay so where where does this whole
concept come from um it actually was
borrowed from like very you know
standard uh uh radio transfer physics I
think there's like some story of like
Pat henan has this like B this bedside
table when he's like working on volume
rendering in the 90s um but yeah people
in the very very early days of Graphics
like in the 70s ' 80s 90s already were
doing stuff like this uh and rendering
these um partially transparent 3D
volumetric objects and this very quickly
turned into like a pretty rigorous
physical theory for being able to render
like all of these phenomena absorption
by like black smoke emission by like a
flame an out scattering and in
scattering you get from like um little
water particles and things like that in
clouds uh people also not only for this
like kind of idea of 3D Volume rendering
people borrowed this this idea of Alpha
compositing and like the alpha
compositing uh algebra for doing digital
compositing in VFX Moody production so
this like let people now say okay I'm
not going to have to render Everything
at Once I'm going to split the scene
into layers I'm going to render them I'm
just going to like pce them on top of
each other using these Alpha layers um
at the end of the day which like makes
the production process a little more
clean and easy uh and then the very
similar volume rendering model as the
one used in Nerf was actually used for a
lot of three Medical Data visualization
starting in the 90s with like Mark level
I group and others so people realize
like we have this data from CT from MRI
um where there's not like a great way to
visualize it except like we have we can
do slices or we can kind of like look at
it projected like from the outside but
it's actually very convenient to take
these kind of uh density scans like you
know the amount of whatever water that
MRI is measuring and just convert that
into a volumetric density field for
rendering uh people also went through a
phase like around 10 or 15 years ago of
thinking maybe we should convert every
surface we have into a volume uh people
were saying like oh this is stuff with
like grid based structures where we can
do pre-filtering really easily right
triangle methods are very hard to
pre-filter because they're not regular
data structures they exist on this like
irregular uh set of points but a grid
you can go and you say I'm going to
filter like every 3x3 block of this this
underlying uh explicit grid so there was
a moment where people showed that like
yeah you can actually basically
approximate any surface as a discretized
volume uh that's just you know like very
opaque or has like surface normals and
do regular shading on
that okay so getting into the the actual
functions here uh for Nerf specifically
we kick out the really expensive uh part
of volume rendering which is scattering
so we assume the ray goes through the
volume it's just going to go in that
direction in a straight line it's not
going to like turn it's not going to
bounce it's not going to hit anythings
which is very convenient uh because then
we don't have this kind of like
arbitrarily long like thousand bounce
path you can get when you're doing full
like fluffy white cloud rendering with
the sun Illuminating it um so this is
basically in physics I think it would
potenti be physically plausible to
instantiate a Nerf as some kind of like
black body cloud of particles but it
would never actually occur in nature so
you're never going to see one of these
things in the wild um but yeah the
things that happen here are basically
particles block a little a little bit of
the light from behind them and they emit
a little bit of light in the direction
of the camera along the
r and that leads us to this like um
probabilistic uh infinitesimal
interpretation of what's going on so we
assume like every uh little like
differentiable differential volume in
space is filled with tiny colored
particles of some density uh and then
our job is to say like okay if a ray
travels through that cloud of particles
where is it probably going to stop in
expectation what color are we going to
see so okay we want to know basically
the the distribution uh over T along the
race so that we can take an expected
value over the colors being emitted by
the
cloud and then return that back to the
camera and yeah unlike surface rendering
this is a kind of a soft prob ballistic
notion uh we assume that we have like
the ground to thing that we're given to
describe the geometry of the scene is
the per uh per volume unit density of
particles at each point um and then if
we scale that by a differential length
along the aray that actually gives us a
a proper uh probability like that the
chance that we would stop exactly will
traversing that tiny differential DT
through the
volume so the problem here is okay we
know the probability that we stop there
but what's the probability we actually
get to that point along the ray right so
we may have arrived at that point and I
want to know what's going to happen but
what about like the rest of the volume
that might have blocked us beforehand um
so the idea here is that like we want to
be able to turn that volume Den to the
sigma into this other function capital T
for transmittance that tells us okay
what's a probably we didn't hit anything
before we got to this little volume
we're looking at
now so we combine these two things we
get an actual uh PDF essentially we're
combining the probability that the we
didn't hit any of the particles before t
with the probability we stop exactly at
T and that gives us T Sigma DT
here uh and you can actually just set up
a simple differential equation to solve
for T given Sigma because of this fact
uh so we can write this out in exactly
that same way convert it into um
equations here so the key fact here is
that if we actually didn't hit something
in the little different differential
volume at DT that multiplicatively
combines with the previous capital T to
give us T of D plus DT Little D Little T
um because if we don't hit something
then we keep Tsing the volume and then
we want to know do we stop at the place
you know t plus
DT uh so we can just write this out here
and then if we use like a linear
approximation to expand that one minus
Sigma DT um oh no sorry a linear
approximation to expand T of T of Little
T plus tdt this is not made for for
English language um yeah we can
rearrange solve we just get a very
familiar equation for uh log of x and
that shows us that we get this
exponential uh property that tells us
okay the propert the probability that we
make it to that point T in the first
place uh is just this like negative
exponentiated integral of all the
density we would have passed through
beforehand uh and something kind of
increasingly interesting in here since
we did nface that this is actually a
score function which people care about a
lot more these days um because uh we see
here if we just flip that back to right
Sigma in terms of t uh it's actually the
instantaneous gradient of the log of
that transmitt property and this is
something that shows like there's always
this kind of question of like what if we
have this unbounded Sigma field and we
do this like exponential function on it
why does that give us this like proper
PDF and CDF um this kind of relates
those facts and explains
that okay so we combine the equation we
got for capital T with Sigma we get the
full PDF along the
ray um and then all we want to do with
Nerf is return the expected value of the
color field integrated against that PDF
but the problem here is okay capital T
actually has another integral hiding
inside of the we just solved for um so
the problem is like we can't just do
naive quadrature where are like we chop
this thing up and we say we can evaluate
each point uh approximately because each
of those points we need to evaluate
we're still gonna have to go evaluate
capital t
so the way we do this is okay we
actually do proper quadrature on the
inner nested integral with an assumption
that each of these segments has constant
density and
color and then we do uh an integral on
top of the neest on of the inner
integral to find the the final
expression for the approximate sum
here okay so this means that we split
the ray up into a bunch of little
segments uh and then we assume we have a
constant sample from each of these
practice this means like okay you sample
a bunch of points along the the array
you send them through whatever your
underlying scene representation is and
you say okay we're going to use that
value at a single point is an
approximation for the value in the
entire
interval and this means we can break up
this integral into a series of sums over
each of those piece-wise constant
segments and for each of the piecewise
constant parts of the volume we do
actually evaluate the proper integral
with the nested part here um because you
need to essentially account for if you
have like a long interval going through
a very dense part of the volume the
transmittance actually is going to fall
to zero like that interval itself is
just going to include the entire thing
you need to account for that or else you
get like an unbounded some above um in
your
approximation all right so that's the
idea of like okay if you have this very
like dark Smoky interval you're going to
not see anything by the time you get to
the end of
it and this goes back to the fact that
again we can break up T as the product
of two things because the chance you
don't hit anything through part and
attention you don't anything through
this part are actually just um
independent probability events so we can
multiply them
um and that gives us this uh we get this
expression for okay how much light was
block blocked by all the previous
segments until we got to this one and
then how much light is blocked partway
through the current segment um so
because we have this uh approximation
for Sigma as piecewise constant this
thing is analytically tractable and it
is just this expression here based on
the distance we traversed through the
interval okay so we substitute that in
here um we evaluate that second level of
integration uh and this is where kind of
a mysterious thing happens here where
these sigmas actually cancel out in the
numerator and the denominator uh and a
lot of people get confused here because
you have this like the top left equation
where there's a capital T and there's a
sigma and then that Sigma disappears in
the final quadrature estimate and that's
because of this like fact that we
accounted for the the partial occlusion
within each interval uh because if you
did just like a direct estimate of this
it would be T * Sigma * C evaluated
discreetly along the the Ray and because
Sigma can be arbitrarily large that's
actually a really bad thing to do
because you would have Sigma of like 100
with a sufficiently long interval and
you'll get like a way way off estimate
for the final color so this one minus
exponential of minus Sigma time Delta is
obviously bounded below at um bounded
above and below by by 0 and one because
we know Sigma is always positive so that
that works out
better uh and this is very cleanly
connected to the idea of alpha
compositing if we just relabel each of
these um one minus X terms as Alpha then
you get exactly the standard thing that
you would see in like you know Photoshop
or illustrator if you're compositing
layers on top of each other with Alphas
uh which is really
nice and then yeah so this is everything
written up in one place um the key thing
here is that like all of this stuff is
just smooth functions right like none of
these things are non- differentiable in
terms of the underlying C and sigma
Fields um so if we just implement this
thing then it's trivially optimizable in
any autoi framework that we
want something else that's really nice
with this connection to Alpha
compositing is a It's associated along
array so you can actually like pre-
composite together this chunk of the the
blue cloud and that chunk of the Green
Cloud keep them as separate image layers
and then Alpha composite them in 2D
space after the fact um this lets you do
things like you know in orig had this
like really dumb video of a a ball like
moving through a scene to demonstrate we
had actual 3D and I do this by just like
I Alpha composite everything in front of
the ball everything behind the ball and
I like stick the ball layer inside as a
synthetic thing and yeah you also get
like with these dream Fusion outputs
they exist like volumetrically in 3D so
you can trivially like just you know
compose them into a scene and rendle
that together with correct occlusions
observed another thing about this
equation is that the
um interpreting it the the expectation
of color over this underlying PDF is
very useful because it makes you think
okay what other quantities would it be
interesting to take the the expectation
over um and we often refer to these
things as like the rendering ways right
them like w and and papers and code uh
because like these things are just super
super useful you can swap in like a
feature Vector you can swap in like a
distance it doesn't have to be color
that you're integrating
against there's also an interesting
aspect here where like Sigma is this
nice scalar Field property this PDF of T
* Sigma is not right this is not just a
3D function it's actually a 5D function
essentially because it cares which
direction you're looking right the
direction you integrate along the ray
means that like you actually see the
correct occlusion on different size of
objects even though you just had this
like underlying 3D field defining the
the PDF um given
array and yeah like I said you can use
this distribution for whatever you want
um the way we got depth map visil
stations out of original Nerf was taking
expected distance along the ray so
substitute T distance along the ray
instead of c um later we ended up
deciding like oh we maybe like median or
like the top end Mode's better because
you kind of see like the Peaks better in
the weight distribution um that's
something interesting where like at
grazing angles because Nerf is still
volumetric you can get this kind of
Cloudy halo effect around things um
especially when it's reconstructing
stuff at such high accuracy that it's
it's like modeling this effect happening
in the real world because you know with
a camera like if you have a mixed pixel
that's like
looking directly at an inclusion
boundary it's doing an integral over
some footprint so you do get a mixture
of the background and the foreground
color you kind of get a similar thing
with Nerf where it does like a partial
opacity Halo at the edge of things to
model that
um that pre filtering effect um so yeah
you don't want to get that in the actual
depth MTH because you want the depth
that correspond to a real point on the
scene so that's one reason to take like
the median or the mode instead of just
the
mean yeah and like I said we can do this
also with with feature vector
people have used this to effect to um
distill things like clip or dyo features
into a 3D field on top of um the Nerf
geometry as well as just color and then
you get this persistent 3D field you can
query uh and you get like a a
segmentation that exists actually in 3D
instead of being like a per per image
frame thing so it's perfectly consistent
as you change the camera
Viewpoint now the other interesting
interpretation of density is that you
can actually take the the the gradient
being like you know the direction of
steepest change of the density field and
you can treat that as a normal Vector
that defines a surface and people often
do this to get like normals out of Nerf
because the way the geometry evolves
over grain descent is that you actually
kind of get it converging to like have a
very very sharp transition and that
often aligns with the the perpendicular
direction of the surface pretty nicely
um so I think this is this might have
had like a little bit of extra
regularization to encourage it to to get
better normal normal vectors on
top okay so that's that's volume
rendering um and now I wanted to talk a
bit about the underlying scene
representation so the volume rendering
stuff is like that's mostly just like
math that's a thing that still like
exists the the scene representation is a
little bit more of an opinionated man
where like this has been fluctuating a
lot since like original Nerf at NLP and
like followup stuff export all kinds of
different representations and you know
of course now there's like ains and
things like that um but I'll get a
little bit into the motivation behind
how we set this up in original Nerf uh
and and why that worked as it did okay
so this is the this is the neural aspect
of calling this you know neural Vol Vol
metric rendering so the idea here this
is something that really came into Vogue
in like 2019 roughly uh with like deep
SDF and other other works that that did
a similar thing there was a couple
examples of people doing this earlier
but it was really this kind of like toy
thing like I think there's a hard Maru
blog post about it and and some other
like small papers exploring the idea of
representing images inside neural
networks and things like that um but
it's really it's kind of a mindset shift
but beyond the idea that like a neural
network takes in a sophisticated
high-dimensional sample of data and
produces some inference about it this is
the idea that like the thing that goes
into this network is super dumb right
it's a 2d or 3D coordinate and then the
thing we're getting out of it is complex
but only an aggregate right so we have
to basically brot Force evaluate this
thing densely over many many 3D points
to get out the actual shape that it
encodes the the input and output at a
single point is almost meaningless right
it's like XYZ to a single color and a
single density value locally it doesn't
tell you anything it's only holistically
through like the entire set of weights
and all the input and output domain that
you actually get something interesting
here and in the case of Nerf it's one
shape right so like you start this thing
from scratch random initialization of
the weights every single time you're
optimizing it for any scene which is
another thing that's like kind of hard
to a mindset shift to like get people to
understand in the context of showing
them a network people expect like big
data set generalization and so on so
forth but like this is more like it's
like a triangle mesh essentially the
purpose that's serving
here um yeah so oh this is a Ma's
animation of you put a point in you get
some geometric information out if you
query it a ton of times then you kind of
get information about the entire
shape
yeah
t all right all right um so yeah like I
said this was kind of a thing that it
popped up all over the place I think
pretty much concurrently across
occupancy networks dsdf a few other
papers there's one at nurs at the same
time um a bunch of people had this idea
of like hey let's see what happens if we
try to encode geometric shape
information into a neural network is
like you know you can interpret it as
like oh the neural neural network is
giving you like the the decision level
set of like am I inside or outside the
shape in 3D um and one thing common to
most of the works is that they were
actually focused on generalization more
than like this single shape
reconstruction task like often they
would show like one toy motivating
example of like oh we baked the Stanford
bunny into this network but then like
what they really care about is baking
like every shape net car into the
network um so this idea was like already
in the air that you should consider
doing this for like a single scene at a
time but it was not really treated as
like a serious Endeavor like it could
get you anything beyond like a more
proper
method and I think one of the reasons
there was that these MLPs at the time
like really were very bad at
representing the high frequency
components of the functions that they
were trying to to optimize um so
something we saw here was like okay
forget nerve forget 3D what if we just
go back to a 2D image and we try to
solve for a network that maps from Pixel
coordinates to Output
colors in this
case excuse me in this case with a
vanilla MLP you get something like this
which is really annoying because the snw
workk has more parameters than there are
actual pixels in the image so why is
this thing so bad like we spent a couple
weeks like initially in the the
beginning stages of Nerf kind of dealing
with this like really annoying
blurriness effect where we're saying
like Okay this thing everyone's been
telling me MLPs are a universal function
approximator for like 10 years but like
that's clearly not a very good function
approximator like what's going on um and
the thing we found here sort of
empirically at first was kind of just
like thinking okay we're essentially
putting a 2d very low frequency mesh
grid through this uh MLP and expecting
to get out a very high frequency signal
this like picture of a wolf or whatever
and that's like putting this like you
know very slow moving coordinate through
this network and expecting to get out
like an arbitrary waveform or something
in 1D um so the idea here was like let's
just give the network more frequencies
like it still can be this analytic thing
this like known deterministic mapping
but let's just help the network out like
boosts its lip shits makes its gradients
a little crazier by giving it like a a
more faster varying signal and if you do
this basically just put every uh every
one of every the mesh grid coordinates
through a bunch of signs and cosines of
increasing frequency you actually get
this thing to converge essentially like
instantly compared to what it was doing
before and it turns out there's a
there's a bunch of like underlying
Theory here sort of explaining that
networks themselves are biased to very
very low frequency components uh of the
inits and if you but you can actually
just manipulate that by giving them
these higher frequencies to work with um
and I yeah okay this is these are matth
sides he has like a very nice high level
like uh philosophical interpretation of
why this might be the case here so okay
if we think about two 2D Idan points
that we're putting through a network
here they're right next to each other
the image can have an arbitrarily high
frequency change right you can go from
black to white or like across an
occlusion edge here uh White to red when
it hits this triangle but the two inputs
are essentially indistinguishable like
that you know if you color map them you
basically can't see the difference with
your eyes so okay it's no no surprised
that the network can't do this either
you can make some argument like okay the
re is allow to have some discontinuities
like it can kind of fit those to the
thing but it turns out it's just like
there's not enough like reu to kind
piece together to fit every single Pixel
in a high frequency um image
correctly um so the idea here is
like if we provide these phal encoding
components even a small shift if you map
it through a sufficiently high frequency
sinusoid you actually can very easily
distinguish between these two points the
low frequency components look very
similar but the high frequency component
changes a lot it's kind of almost like
feeding the um float representation of
the number or like you know a fix Point
representation of the number through as
a one hot Vector you're like giving it
these components that fluctuate way more
quickly as you move through space than
just like the raw floating Point values
themselves uh and you got these very
like nice behaviors here where so okay
this this is just showing if you scale
up the maximum frequency of the sinoid
you apply to the the inut 2D coordinates
and do this image memorization task um
you get this very very clean scaling
Behavior where like the more frequency
components you provide the the better
the training loss get so this is psnr so
high is good so once you hit psnr of
like 45 it's essentially perfect like
that's like floating Point error like
quantization error from the 8bit image
um the interesting thing here is that
you also hurt the generalization of the
network generalization using kind of a
weird sense here where we're talking
about like okay if we look what happens
between two of those like discrete uh
grid coordinates corresponding to the
center of these pixels and we see like
what's the function Behavior like
between the pixels it gets crazier and
crazier as you give it more
frequencies because essentially like if
you're giving it frequencies that are
way way higher than the the actual like
pitch of the pixels in the image uh it
can way overfit to that signal and it's
basically noise uh and it's not going to
do anything intelligent if you like try
to upsample that image by like two or 4X
and and CER it on a denser GD of
coordinates this is showing the output
on the left is querying the image at 2x
the resolution it was trained supervised
on so you can see that it kind of loses
its mind and like starts soliciting a
bunch of crazy stuff in between the
pixels as you give it larger and larger
um frequencies so there's always this
kind of like sweet spot in the middle um
in the days where we were still using
this positional encoding for a lot of
stuff with MLPs you always have to like
kind of roughly tune this thing until
you got not over blurring and not uh
over like sparkly aliasing artifacts
from giving it too much to work with so
yeah this is results we had in the
follow-up paper to Nerf that explored
this idea of positional coding more uh
in Nerf we were with the original paper
we were trying to find other tasks we
could like squeeze into the original
submission to say like oh this is so
General it's so cool you can do this
with the um low dimensional networks now
uh we kind of ended up packaging that
into later paper we sent to nurs there
was this fora feature paper um and we
had a couple tasks there which was like
this is encoding the SDF of a shape so
not precisely the same as Nerf because
this is an MLP that maps from points to
distance to a surface given like a
ground through 3D shape just memorizing
it you can see that you basically the
top thing was like the level of quality
you could get with deep SDF or something
like that before but to actually get
like normal service detail um you need
this kind of positional encoding to
boost the frequency content in the
networ uh same thing with like we did a
toy MRI task uh and then like a toy Nerf
task to to get some metrics for the
paper and this was like you know this is
actually the original scene we tested
this method on in Nerf uh and i' kind of
been like struggling for weeks with the
results like the one on the left where I
was thinking like oh this MLP thing is
pretty cool but like it's not really
high resolution enough to ever be like
state of the art like it's cool that
this thing is an MLP intellectually but
it's not like actually a useful method
but then you just put this positional
encoding thing and you kind of magically
solve all your problems with essentially
no extra compute or memory requirements
at all um it's kind of just like a
neural network reconditioning thing that
that makes conversions much
better um so something here I mentioned
like the original Nerf fuse position
coding with frequencies that were powers
of two uh in the later work we proposed
using like frequencies sampled from a
gaan distribution or something um you
might think okay those are just
parameters let's learn those as well why
don't we just put those uh through GR
descent as well as the MLP
weights and the idea here is like it
turns out that like as soon as you start
training this thing um you kind of get
the the signal evolving and lock set
with that underlying parameterization
like you can imagine that if you change
the the
frequency it's tied to the input spatial
coordinates in a way that like it
essentially scales up and down the shape
of the object so you got this Global
lock in effect where like the
frequencies maybe can drift a tiny bit
at initialization but then they have
this like Global dependency on each
other and on the signal being optimized
it means that they just can't move right
um just Matt's explanation of this and I
was trying to understand what he was
implying but I didn't quite get it so
yeah
um yeah so so the idea here is like okay
what can we do to make this thing
learnable maybe we don't have these like
Global sinusoidal functions anymore
maybe we actually like chop this up and
we have more locally spatially localized
features that we can learn uh and the
clear solution here is like okay let's
go back let's get discretized Space
let's have like you know maybe a voxal
grid of features that we feed through an
MLP to be acting as a learned kind of
encoding and the whole reason we and a
lot of other people were looking into
this MLP thing in the first place is
this like cursive dimensionality in 3D
right so grids are fine for image you
know people are now feeling the pain of
grids for video but like it's still sort
of okay and you have like a dense signal
to make it be reasonable but there's
really no good justification for having
a dense 3D grid uh sampling shapes in
space because they're naturally super
sparse right shapes are like this 2D
manifold existing in 3D space so having
a dense 3D sampling at high resolution
is completely wasteful
um and yeah the um the way yeah yeah so
back to the encoding thing the way
people made these encodings continuous
uh to use them as similar way to the
sinuso just like oh you can actually
just feed uh a TR trilinear
interpolation of these feature vectors
through uh as an encoding and that turns
out to work like very very well so this
was a paper uh like I don't know like a
year year and a half after Nerf there
was a whole set of like three papers or
four papers at the same conference that
basically were like get rid of that big
MLP just use like a 128 256 Cub boxal
grid use Tri interpolation uh with a
little MLP or some activation function
on it and that actually still gives you
like high frequency enough edges that
that it can work quite well right and so
back to the idea of this like
wastefulness of the dense 3D grid
there's a couple different directions
people have gone to amortize that fact
uh and reduce it down to like a more
manageable uh scale as you get higher
resolution in 3D uh and those are
basically like different methods of
sparsification you can apply to the
data um so there's like literal
sparsification in which you just
greedily optimize check for empty space
and like cut it out so you have like
your your fine grid resolution and at
some corser resolution you're going to
like inspect each cube in space see if
there's Sensi there if there's not you
just say like this is dead there's
nothing here I'm never going to look
here again I'm going to create some
acceleration structure that just marks
all of the like coar empty cubes skip
over them when I'm traversing samples
along the Ray and only sample from the
places where the actual geometry is and
people like iteratively do this over and
over again over the course of
optimization like every you know 5,
steps just take a look check out the
non-empty space see if it's still really
non empty and then keep track of that
over
time people have done other so that's
like a very like you know discreet
puristic thing that you have to
implement yourself and go Brute Force
query for where there's density and
where there's not there's sort of like
more intermediate things like these low
rank approximations where people will
just say okay I'm never going to
instantiate a dense 3D Volume what I'm
going to do is always learn that thing
in a a factorized low rank
representation um so there's like tensor
RF and some other related work that did
this where they would say okay I can
like represent a 3D Volume as a low rank
outer product of like you know three 1D
vectors or like maybe a 2d plane and a
1D Vector where like I I project on the
zis and grab a feature and I project
down into the XY plane and grab another
feature and I like add or multiply them
together uh and this works pretty nicely
like the representation here especially
this this representation from the EG 3D
paper called a tripl has really really
persisted through a lot of the
generative work because it's this nice
like clean representation for a 3D
volume based on a set of 2D feature
planes which you can just glue into a
bunch of like existing image generation
architectures another interesting method
is these things called like a dictionary
method so okay well inant NGP is kind of
like one of the most well-known like
Nerf follow-ups that basically got the
the training time for the synthetic
scenes down to like a second or two from
the original day or two that it took us
with the MLPs and the way they did this
was they basically outsourced all of the
work of the MLP to this underlying
spatial hash grid uh and they got around
the the resolution issue by saying like
Okay space is sparse so we can use like
a really aggressive hash function that
just Maps a ton of points to collide
with each other in space and most of
them won't hit the surface so the
Collision will kind of naturally resolve
itself and we're using gradient descent
so it will also resolve itself just
through like learning and optimization
right we'll sort of like let the thing
figure itself out we're going to give it
this hash function mapping and it can
like use these features to store stuff
spatially as it will uh and resolve the
collisions just by like the way that
best optimizes re-rendering
Lo yeah and one thing all of these have
in common is like they actually ends up
still usually being a small MLP at the
end of the day so in particular when
people want to represent outgoing like
view dependent appearance as a function
of Ray Direction they'll like feed that
signal through the MLP along with a
feature or if you want to have some like
appearance and coding vector or
something like that people will just
take this like spatial memory bank use
it to grab a feature incate that with
other interesting information and then
feed that through a small MLP
um yeah and like there's I guess was
kind of just like oscillating like tied
of research uh thinking like okay so for
a while we thought boxal are untenable
we can't use them like it's not going to
work and then it turned out like after
we tried the MLPs boxal are still not so
bad as long as we sort of sparsify them
very aggressively or use one of these um
learn sparsification
structures so it got to the point where
there's sort of like you know take down
papers like you don't naly after all
like gotcha um but it's it's like okay
sure like the underlying like framework
is still basically the same of this like
single seam optimization with the volume
metric Runing model and like yeah it's
not super surprising that we can find
other ways to represent this signal uh
spatially and um yeah it's sort of like
everyone's still like going in this kind
of spiral of like trying different
representations and different
combinations for different test there's
obviously a big difference between test
where like you're just doing a pure
optimization Loop to render a single
scene versus things where like I want to
output something 3D from a feed for
Network those lend themselves to like
totally different representations um but
there's still kind of like not consensus
on either side of like which one of
these things is really going to work and
like that's been most clearly
demonstrated over the last year by like
the gou and stuff right you know
everything that's been done has been
Rewritten uh in a gausian version by now
uh and it's going to be really
interesting to see like okay where do
this thing end up going like there's a
bunch of very clear advantages so that
where like you have actual discrete
particles representing the geometry of
you seene you can use rest and so so
forth um but there's kind of like this
classic like ukian lran tradeoff of like
when do you want a grid but when you
want like explicit particles it's been
playing itself out in like physical
simulation world for decades and I
expect to see a lot of like similar back
and forth and like okay when do we want
to have a structured output on a grid
when don't we want to have this like
loose kind of collection of
particles okay so yeah back to the the
original Nerf results um yeah so yeah
this was this is the original Nerf paper
again with this like eight layer MLP
volume rendering um dependent effects uh
we rendered this synthetic data set of
objects from I think like blend swap or
Turbo squid meshes because at the time
there wasn't really a proper review
synthesis data set for these challenging
type of objects where there's like very
complex geometry and there's a specular
Reflections I think by this point
performance is mostly saturated on the
data set we rendered out 100 uses of
each of these objects we actually
originally rendered 400 thought that
sounded not impressive enough so went
down to 100 um and these days I I think
like you know psnr is like 35 or
something like people should probably
stop using these essentially uh but at
the time it was it was a big step up
over above the complexity of the
previous data sets yeah we also had
these kind of like forward basing tasks
which people surprisingly do some still
use um this was mostly just an issue of
like how are we going to handle
unbounded space uh in original Nerf we
actually just had like a method to
compress essentially like a forward
facing volume into a single Cube by
using like a one over Z mapping um so
that's why we focus on this kind of
scene uh we had a couple of these very
carefully staged like 360 renderings but
this actually relies on the fact that
the camera is pointed down toward the
object in such a way that you don't see
the Horizon like if you keep looking
farther away from this object you
actually end up seeing that like the
Horizon is a total mess in these cases
and only the object and its immediate
surroundings are constructed uh
cleanly okay um so yeah given given that
summary of of the stuff underlying
original Nerf I kind of made a takeaway
slide talking about like okay which of
these things are still like reasonable
conclusions so which of these are like
totally outdated at this point I think
it's interesting to look at these four
attributes where one is the MLP for
shape like I talked about uh in the
representation section uh the other I
didn't talk about quite as much like
this idea that we were encapsulating
view dependent appearance as part of the
MLP function mapping uh the idea of
doing this optimization of over a single
scene at once instead of trying to
generalize uh and the idea of course I
talked a lot about the the volume
rendering equation um and yeah like I
said no this is proposed by Nerf all it
just kind of like United to to solid uh
performance in the original paper we
did I think yeah MLPs for shape is kind
of dumb at the end of the day like it's
it's it's intellectually curious that an
MLP can do this but I think very
impractical essentially um the only
extent to which it's really interesting
is like the MLP is actually a very
compact shaped representation it's like
5 megabytes in original Nerf compared to
most of the discretized equivalents you
might have there's a kind of like higher
level like deep learning takeaway thing
here and that MLPs are actually really
good regularizers for low-dimensional
spatial signals so people have started
exploiting this like I I've seen you
know you might think like MLP for
spatial signal it's done like no one's
going to do that anymore but people have
adopted it quite a lot for these
deformation tracking base works so even
if maybe like the underlying scene
representation is still agreed in like
this deformable Nerf or something um the
idea of using an MLP to track like okay
from time T to time t plus one like
where does this point move that actually
has a very like low frequency spacal
signature um that Maps very well on the
kind of smoothness that an MLP imposes
uh on the reconstructed signal en codes
and we actually already kind of knew
that because of deep image prior and
similar Works where people have observe
like if you take a unit uh you feed
random noise into it and you Rec you
optimize it to reconstruct a single
image like I just take the noisy image
on the left I use that as the L2 lost
Target for a unit like no other images
at all no input besides noise you
actually get this effectively like dno
version of the image and we they showed
you could do this for like inpainting
and and super resolution other kind of
similar tasks um so this this phenomenon
of like the empir the empirical
smoothness regularization of MLP had
already been uh investigated quite a bit
um and we were kind of like still like
repeatedly amazed ourselves at like why
isn't this thing just like why isn't
there a bunch of garbage floating around
in the scene because we had tried doing
direct Vox grid optimization before we
tried the MLP stuff and you always get
these kind of like fuzzy clouds and
these things annoying things like
floating around but the MLP just has
like the precise right amount of
capacity and smoothness to represent
these signals in a convenient
way um and yeah like I said before it's
actually it's quite compact uh signal
representation um in the case of
memorizing an image like I was showing
with the fox image you actually can't
really make the network weight small
enough to represent that image decently
and have it compete with like a JPEG or
something but but something funny that
we realized a lot was like with a Nerf
like the um the MLP weights would be
smaller than the MP4 renderings we baked
out from the Nerf like that this was
actually a pretty compact representation
of the scene um yeah and with um again
with with image and video like the
codecs you use to compress it are are
like very very precisely engineered by
people they work really well they're
like designed for human perception but
they're not natively differentiable
which is the problem right so like if
you want to recover a naturally sparse
signal and you never want to instantiate
the uncompressed version of it so like
you you you have this dense 3D signal
and you know like I can never afford to
make you know like 4,000 cubed volume
maybe on like a H1 or now you could but
not on 8 gigabytes or whatever um so you
want to be like I I need this thing to
kind of be differentiably compressed
while I'm optimizing it MLPs serve
really well to to do that um but yeah
you know once once you kind of get the
final output it still makes sense to
like bake it out into a properly
compressed format you can have just like
a empty space skipping structure like
density query the thing um shipping the
MLP is like an actual like file format
essentially never makes
sense oh yeah um yeah the next thing I
wanted to mention was yeah this idea of
using an MLP for be defendant appearance
I didn't touch on that much in in this
version of The Talk um but it's still
kind of back and forth on this one like
the basically you need a a function
basis for
representing uh color values on a sphere
um and then MLP Works about as well as
any of the other things people have been
trying and it's it's more compact in
some of them right like spherical
harmonics kind of blow up for high
frequencies spherical ganss are fine but
um the MLP Works quite well in original
Nerf we would do these like dense
queries for a single 3D point in the
scene query all outgoing directions and
see what how did the color change as you
did that if you do that for an actually
shiny object you get this kind of nice
effect of like oh I see like a localized
white highlight at the grazing angle on
the ship and on the
water and it's like the same kind of
thing you see with uh uh explicit
parameterized representations like gausi
living on a
sphere okay I think this idea of doing
like an inverse framework optimization
to do single same 3D reconstruction is
really good and we've seen it proven to
scale to ridiculously large scenes like
I never doing a original Nerf I would
never have expected you could just do
the same framework with like a bigger
scene representation and more images and
get something like this out of it this
is like one of the Google New York cafes
I think this is from 1500 images and
it's just a big NGP grid underlying it
you know the Senor presentation now
balloons to like 200 megabytes but it's
still at the end of the day the same
just like sample random pixels uh apply
an L2 loss to them and optimize for
25,000 iterations
uh and you can get this kind of
reconstruction out and it's really like
it goes against the kind of like feed
forward Paradigm of like oh we want to
feed every single input image in and get
the thing out wholesale which is this
like Loop of optimization yeah so I just
thought like a general like big picture
question so like I think the Nerf is
super impressive in terms of just like
as a compression technique how it's able
to like capture all this photo realism
with like such a small MLP but like what
I'm curious about is like for
applications outside of Graphics like
for robotics for example where you have
like very Dynamic scenes like you have
to retrain this every time the scene
changes and like I seen like neural
radian skill are like very popular in
robotics but I'm also a little bit
confused by the popularity because of
the lack of Dynamics because my
understanding is it's basically
overfitting to the scene like it just
basically learns the exact scene so it's
basically like a very powerful
compression technique um so do you think
it's possible to ever make this dynamic
in like real time in terms of like 20
Herz 30 Hertz or is that not possible to
like train a neural net to update that
fast yeah I mean in terms of the first
consideration of like making it Dynamic
there's actually been the huge amount of
followup work that just will add like a
deformation field or the ability to like
disentangle components and move them
separately so like that stuff has has
and especially with with the gaou and
stuff now like it's just a bunch of
points so like you can just freely move
stuff around you can solve for like a
tracking like field that keeps keeps Sy
in 3D so like every object you could
imagine disentangling if you have enough
observations in terms of like 20 or 30
Herz I think that's like another
question like people have been pushing
uh like for a while they were working on
like Nerf type slam things now gaan type
slam things that actually can run pretty
fast those are mostly to map out static
scenes uh I think like doing this live
and keeping track of deformable objects
is harder I have seen actually some
results people did with multi viw camera
setups where they're all streaming video
um where you can kind of like you take
each multiv view step uh and then you do
a pretty quick update of a few steps of
gradient descent to just like kind of
relocalize where stuff moved or like
maybe like reconstruct new things that
emerg in the scene um I think it's still
like like I
I yeah it's not it's it's at like a base
level just like getting this like frozen
reconstruction this compressed of the 3D
geometry is not actually that useful he
doesn't even tell you like affordances
and like what can move in the scene and
things like that so yeah I think
basically like you said you need a lot
more data on top that like puristic
disentangles the components or like
keeps track them as they move and things
like that so in that case like if it's
mostly useful for like static scenes
like you said then what do you think are
like useful Downstream applications for
this like is it more like AR and VR or
like yeah I think this is not that
useful I think mostly it's useful in
that it motivates progress in like other
better pipelines that do like deformable
stuff or disentangled stuff or things
like that I think like this is basically
an academic problem that motivated a lot
of improvement in 3D representations and
reconstruction in a way that like spread
itself out into all those more useful
versions of itself essentially right
like I think having this thing baked out
it's like basically it's good for making
these fun videos and maybe like selling
your house but like not that useful for
other St um yeah looks fun but yeah it's
very it's very academic essentially yeah
I think that's totally
true um okay yeah I'm just gonna go
through like four more slides here um
yeah so I think on my little self-report
card here I think uh the final Point uh
of this question of volume rendering I
think this is just like proven itself to
be a very useful Paradigm for doing
reconstruction and optimization we've
basically seen most things that like
claim they're doing a hard surface
optimization these days actually
optimize a volume parameterized by the
hard surface like we see this kind of
stdf type things that like can rot the
stf into a volume to optimize it and we
just see that like the properties if you
want to start with like no aror
information about where the things in
your scene are besides like maybe a
bounding box this just it converts so
cleanly and so fast and so reliably um
that it's hard for me to imagine
bootstrapping a surface method to work
like especially in a scene like this
right where you what are you g to put
like a sphere in the middle of the scene
unexpected to blow up to the entire room
like I think any any kind of like
surface bake things usually come out as
a result of a downstream processing
where like you start with a volumetric
optimization then maybe you mesh it and
you refine that um so yeah I think that
this volumetric step is just really
really powerful uh and that's been like
that was already happening basically for
like three or four years before Nerf we
were seeing a bunch of different feed
for view synthesis methods that were
using volumetric reconstruction uh and
also like single shaped three
degenerative methods on like very small
Lowes voxal grids that we're using a
similar like mathematical formulation so
that was kind of just like a tide that
was happening and it's continued since
then um I think this seems like a great
stopping point uh to to cut this off I
got through the Nerf slides um no future
slides but